這是第十二集,題目是《對比式解釋》,用幾何跟拓普來看。
講者Marina Miller做流行學習,
研究資料在高位空間裡實際攤成什麼形狀,
反事實解釋這題,
她寫過一篇整理350篇論文的綜述。
這場她把counterfactual這個詞讓給英國那一派,自己的版本叫contrastive,對比式解釋。
先把這集要問的問題講清楚
反事實解釋的標準定義
照他投影片上那一頁
給一筆有標籤的資料集D
每筆標0或1
一個被判成0的查詢點X0
還有一個距離函數D
輸出X1
就是所有標1的點裡面
離X0最近的那一筆
白話講模型拒絕了你
就找一個跟你最像
但被接受的人給你看
那一頁還列了幾條額外要求
X1要可信
不能是資料里根本長不出來的點
從X0到X1的路徑要短
要可信X1要穩定
而且最好用使用者自己的概念來講
幾百種方法都在比
誰找的X1比較好
Miller問的不是這個
他把每一個被拒絕的X0
對到自己的X1
問這個對應本身
第一
是不是每個X0都真的有一個X1
第二
X0挪一點點
X1是跟著挪一點點
還是跳到別的地方去
答案分三段
把F當成地形
解釋就是從你的位置
往上爬到門檻的那條路
地形裡沒有坡度為0的點
兩題都是有
這是他的定理
一有臨界點或有洞
就有人爬到一半停住
有人的解釋
跳開
這是他的反例
最後他換成用概念來爬同一座山
算出兩條路
終點差多少
如果我看出所有的可能的出口
and map them to all the possible outputs
What kind of function is that
That's the goal of this talk
用D型圖來想
F是高度也就是被接受的幾率
它說的level set就是等高線
你站在下面那條套鈴上
門檻是上面那條套
標準做法是找離你最近的一點
它改成走路
從你的位置出發
每一步都走最陡的上坡
這條路叫梯度流
永遠跟等高線垂直
走到tau那條線停下來的地方
就是你的解釋xc
下面那條線上
每一點都這樣走一遍
就是他說的那個對應
他寫成fi
他接著把舞臺畫出來
右邊這張就是
上面那條線是mtau
門檻
下面那條是mtau0
所有起點
左邊綠色的線
是密度剛好等於門檻的地方
他叫這個門檻raw
在過去的點太不可信
不算
中間那個綠圈
是資料裡的一塊空洞
一樣不可信
右邊藍色的線
是資料本來的邊界
兩條綠的加一條藍的
它合稱垂直邊界
繼承B
後面所有的圖都畫在這一塊裡面
坡度為0的地方有三種
山頂
谷底
還有兩座山中間的山口
叫安點
Morse函數多要求一件事
這些點都要乾脆
不能是一整片平臺
Hasson沒有零特徵值
講的就是這個
對解釋來說
臨界點是陷阱
往上爬的路一走進去
最陡的上坡就沒有方向了
路停在那裡
永遠到不了門檻
如果這個圖片沒有圖片
不,如果這個圖片沒有重點
那麼,低層層會跟高層不同
每個x0的輸入都會有x1的解釋
它們都會不同
地圖是可動的
非常非常好
所以,這就是為了有更多理論的原因
因為我們有這個不錯的結果
但是我還沒有證明我們有Morse的功能
我們想要有Morse的功能
這就是為什麼
我之前已經講過
Morse的功能
這其實也有分別
在近距離的解釋
和在任何地方的解釋
因為在近距離
如果這裡沒有重點
那裡會有附近
沒有重點
然後這件好事會發生
所以我們可以說
Hey, this is my contrastive explanation
that it exists always in a neighborhood
我們有一個很相似的解釋
and don't ask me about the rest
把定理拆開看
條件跟結論都在這一頁上
條件一
兩條等高線上本身沒有臨界點
條件二
F的T度在垂直邊界上不跟邊界垂直
白話就是流線不從側邊穿出去
這兩條成立
這一塊在top裡叫cobardism
條件三
整塊裡面都沒有臨界點
結論下面那條M tau0
跟上面那條M tau微分同配
而且這個同配就是T度流本身
翻成人化
每個起點都有解釋
不同的人解釋一定不同
起點連續動
解釋也連續動
為什麼成立沒有臨界點
流線沒有地方可以停
只能從下面一路走到上面
流線彼此不交叉
所以一對一
微分方程的解對起點連續
所以連續
他做的是把這個現成的定理
接到反事實解釋上
引用的是葉上彪
BNR12那篇
帶邊界的摩斯理論
他沒做的他自己講了
還沒證明真實的F沒有臨界點
只保證決策邊界附近有一圈成立
其他地方別問他
他的修法只動邊界
沿垂直邊界留一圈寬度
ε的領域
只在這一圈裡改F
讓梯度貼著邊界走
不再傳出去
其他地方的F不動
原本的臨界點也都還在
代價是多一個參數Epsilon
邊界那一圈的解釋是改過的F給的
修完就只剩臨界點
就是這張圖
最下面那條線是起點
Tau 0
且藍色箭頭是往上爬的路
最上面那條線是門檻
Tau
紅點是臨界點
拿右上角這個缺口來看
從缺口左邊一點點出發的人
停在缺口的左岸
起點往右挪一點點
終點就跳到右岸
中間隔了一整個缺口
這就是Five不連續
正對缺口底部出發的那個人
走進紅點就停住
什麼解釋都拿不到
所以這張圖證明的是
只要有臨界點就有人沒有解釋
而且φ不連續
它沒給的是哪些起點會出事
那一塊有多大
這取決於F的拓撲
在一個圖表上
這實際上是最重要的東西
其實這是最重要的挑戰
我沒有假裝我處理過它
但是基本上
如果我們有一個圖表
我們就不能想起一個全球圖表
看起來像一個真實的圖表
所以我們必須想起
另一個解釋空間的圖表
一個圖表看起來像一個圖表
這就是我想說的
這是我的信息
即使在這個限制中,如果我們提到解釋的穩定性
那旋律不能被忽視,旋律實際上就是跳舞
旋律的描述告訴我們我們所擁有的解釋元素
後半場,他把同一條上坡路換成用概念來走
我們壓成一段,概念是使用者的語言
像腫瘤大小,血流速度,每個概念C都是X的函數
它不逼近F本身
只逼近F的T度在每一點上
F最陡的那隻箭頭
用幾個概念的箭頭加權湊出來
權重β每個點都不一樣
誤差每一點都不超過Delta
接著兩條路從同一個起點出發
一條照真的T度走
一條照湊的走
它的上界
兩個終點的距離不超過Delta除以L
乘上E的L被套
減套0次方再減1
L是F二節導數的上界
白化誤差隨要爬的高度指數放大
它沒做的三件
概念不夠用的情況沒分析
概念到F的對應它假設痊癒成立
流行有動還要多一個痊癒條件
他說那條目前什麼都說不出來
比如說地區的距離必須比較廣
如果地區的距離必須比較廣
這意味著我會越來越需要更多的概念
所以這自然會告訴我
如果我想要向更多失敗的人解釋
我會需要更長的更復雜的解釋
這就是一件不驚人的事情
只是確保我們可能正在正確的路線上
整場收成一句
反事實解釋是一個對應fi
它存不存在
連不連續
由F的地形決定
資料再多也改不了
他做到的
把解釋寫成T度流
證明沒有臨界點時
人人有解釋
而且連續
畫出有臨界點時
誰拿不到
哪裡會跳
還有概念版的誤差上界
他沒做到的
他的結論頁自己列了
解釋應該附上一個複雜度
一部分是路徑長度
一部分是拓撲
兩個怎麼合起來
是開放問題
還有整場都在理想世界裡
F流行密度全當成已知
也沒有實驗
下一場是Columbia大學的
Elias Brainboim
Judia Pearl的學生
因果這一派
Miller把反事實這個詞讓給了因果
Brainboim要講的就是
AI要會做因果推理
才講得出真正的解釋
他的第一個例子是問生徒模型
貓把花瓶推下桌會怎樣
模型自己把墊子拿掉
再讓花瓶摔碎
十歲小孩都看得出不對
最強的模型卻看不出來
原影片連結在說明欄
整場53分鐘
有興趣可以去聽更多